am anfang an grosse panik das ist immer
so in den ersten vier wochen nachdem
eine neue und unbeherrschbar gefahr
erscheint kommt die große panik und dann
gewöhnt sich die leute langsam dran
das heißt also menschen tasten sich an
corona an die ein wildes tier also wie
weit kann ich bis an das krokodil dann
laufen wir bis es mich beißt und genau
das machen viele menschen jetzt in
dieser irrigen meinung jetzt habe ich
drei monate lang einen koran gekriegt
jetzt werde ich das wahrscheinlich auch
nicht mehr kriegen dass wir also
ungefähr wenn wir im auto autofahrer und
drei monate lang den sicherheitsgurt
nicht genommen haben und jetzt sagen
jetzt brauche ich ihnen nicht mehr
offensichtlich eigentlich nicht zu
unfällen
und wenn mit dieser einstellung gehen
wir jetzt viele leute dann das ist immer
so wenn eine panik situation auftritt
dass die leute sich nach einer gewissen
zeit damit arrangieren und corona in die
lange liste der bekannten gefahren
einordnen
aber was kann die politik jetzt machen
um doch dafür zu werben die maßnahmen
jetzt mitzutragen
man muss ja sagen dieser lockt sondern
auch alle anderen maßnahmen helfen nur
wenn wirklich sich die allermeisten
zumindest am besten alle daran halten
ja das ist tatsächlich so jetzt müssen
83 millionen zusammenhalten und viele
verstehen dass ihr bericht und dass die
politik begleitet das im moment muss man
einfach sagen weil der mensch sich sein
eigenes risiko profil erarbeitet also
jeder rechnet sich selber aus wie hoch
die chance ist und das risiko corona
zugehörigen und hört jetzt gar nicht
mehr auf die ratschläge der politiker
als das ist verpufft einfach jeder denkt
ich das so zurecht und das ist eine
fatale einstellung die wahrscheinlich
jetzt auch sehr viele menschenleben
kosten wird weil die leute einfach zu
unvorsichtig werden und das nächste
problem wird sein wenn tatsächlich mal
einen impfstoff kommt dass die politik
dann jede menge
zeit investieren muss den bürgern die
impfpflicht nach nahe zu bringen weil
viele oder die werden sich nicht impfen
lassen in russland am 59 prozent der
leute gesagt ich lasse mich nicht impfen
und genau das befürchte ich auch in
deutschland das selbstständige stoff da
ist und sogar in genügendem engen da ist
dass dann viele leute denken sie müssen
sich jetzt nicht impfen weil das
irgendwie schädlicher als als krone an
zu kriegen
in der kanadischen provinz british
columbia setzt man momentan weniger auf
verbote sondern mehr auf einsicht und
das ganze scheint auch zu funktionen auf
die zahlen schaut bedeutet das dass wir
hier in deutschland ein land der
uneinsichtigen sind die es ohne verbote
nicht hinbekommen nein das glaube ich
nicht mehr sehen
an den zahlen dass deutschland
eigentlich ein einigermaßen gut
weggekommen ist gut es gibt noch andere
länder wo die menschen noch
disziplinierter sind in japan zum
beispiel deutschen in deutschland sind
an sich diszipliniert und auch
vorausschauend denkende im vergleich zu
anderen ländern aber trotzdem würde ich
dann 60 dafür plädieren dass man auf
plädiert auf die einsicht der
bevölkerung dass man den leuten das so
auch ähnlich wie es im nördlichen länder
norwegen schweden und so weiter
geschieht einfach auf die einsicht der
leute baut und nicht immer nur mit
vorschriften und regeln arbeitet
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren